- I just know that there
are people out there
who spend their paychecks on sneakers
and they call themselves sneakerheads.
(electronic music)
- This changes everything, not
being able to see the brand.
- I don't, what is this made out of?
Like, R2D2 skin?
- Someone being on the bball
courts in like, Space Jam.
- This is the white
t-shirt of men's shoes.
Everyone has one.
- I see some, like,
frat boy wearing these.
- I think I'm gonna go
with the basketball shoes,
just 'cause basketball shoes are always
insanely expensive.
- I'm gonna guess that these are $120,
and that these are 240.
- Ooh, I think that
these are more expensive.
No, no, no, no, nope.
I think that these are more expensive.
- Look at the bottom,
it's completely clean.
You have the patriarchy,
you get all the power
and then just to flaunt it, you're like,
we get to wear comfortable shoes,
but we're not gonna (bleep) wear them.
(electronic music)
- Oh my god! I want the
girl version of this shoe.
- These are awesome.
- I feel like these would
be in a Missy Elliott video.
- I don't know what these
are, they look cool, though.
I'm jealous that men just
get to wear comfortable,
there's so much (bleep) padding in this.
- These look exactly
like the basketball shoes
I had in eighth grade, I'm not kidding.
- I feel like these might
be babes or something,
'cause I think these are more expensive.
- I would say these.
- I would pay $175 for my
feet not to hurt all the time.
(electronic music)
- Is this the cool person shoe now?
- This is probably one
of the most ridiculous
things I've ever seen.
- Whoa, there's a shoe inside this boot,
it's a shoe condom.
- That's like a new, hmm, I
guess you'd do that, right?
- I don't understand why men think women
are ridiculous, when this kind of (bleep)
is floating around.
- I'm guessing these are expensive
just 'cause they're really weird.
- I'm gonna say these,
are these more expensive?
What?! Damn it!
- 175, 185.
That can't be right.
Damn it!
- The more expensive ones were uglier.
I was like ... (shrugs)
- That's a lot of money
and I could've gotten
seven kittens out of those pairs of shoes.
- Men are weirder than women.
Why would you spend that much money
on shoes that are not your size
that you cannot wear?
You're not allowed to, or
it's gonna (bleep) them up.
- A brand is worth so
much more than the shoe.
- Oh my god, this says
Why Not on the side.
Maybe these are Hilary Duff's Nikes.
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah, mm-hmm.
You don't know the half of it.